[Music]
the fact that we have had this meeting
today after almost four years without
this meeting taking place is in itself I
believe extremely important we
reaffirmed the importance we attach to
our relations with Turkey which is a
candidate country and a partner of
strategic importance for the European
Union we are very well aware of the
marks left by the attempted coup in
Turkey in 2016 and we recognize the
serious very serious security concerns
that Turkey has but we also see that the
state of emergency is now behind us and
we hope that soon all related measures
will be something of the past
turkey and Catalan Federation all an
all-aluminum ultimate system oughta be
lenient on sega smarter krb amitaba
canada UK mcdaniel year negative message
where is le Clarendon last humans bash
fastin a solution i initially in-house
elector and tamil non-nasa constantly
backed into them is a week arid article
adam the dialogue doesn't mean
antithetical dialogue and sometimes we
had to state that we agree to disagree
the eu-turkey statement has been out
doubt helped to curb illegal migration
from turkey to the Union supported the
fight against smuggling and that above
all it has prevented the appalling loss
of life at sea
I think today's Association Council is
evidence that the Union is sincerely
interested in maintaining an open
constructive dialogue in areas of common
interest to the benefit of balls